[Music]
how you guys doing today i'm going to be
reacting
to a particular segment i've seen
uh from bill maher
and
mike tyson and you're a muslim yeah is
the whole family muslim um
some of my kids but listen um it's my
wife and my kids they have to choose
what they want to be right they have to
choose and you're okay with that
absolutely that is not a point of view
that is even allowed in many many muslim
countries in the world there is one
religion it is islam and
we're not they're not big on like hey
you know what
let's agree to disagree but listen i'm
not allah
i know i'm just
see look at this guy uh bill
maher
first and foremost he's saying let's not
allow the muslim countries
there
there's there's many there's layers of
problems here what is a muslim country
exactly is it a country the majority of
muslim population let's just say that is
the case no problem let's go with that
now is what happens is a muslim country
representative of what islam says
no it's not
okay so it's it's not really a good
argument number three on this point
uh actually there's many verses in the
quran which very clearly tell us that
prophets prophets had their own sons
disagreed with them
their own wives disagreed with them
betrayed them
went against them didn't believe in what
they believed
noah for example was depicted in the
quran as having his son disbelief
or that his son disbelieved and that he
went against him he didn't force him to
become
a submitter to one god
lot as well his wife disbelieved and so
on so the prophet muhammed himself his
uncle abu talib did not believe in the
message of islam and that allah in the
quran says
that you don't guide who you want but
allah guides whomever he wants
so let him dilute him
or the idea that he just negated
to you your religion and to our to us
ours is exactly a verse in the quran
it's not necessarily uh as he says it
women who don't want to wear the [__]
you know
whatever the
thing that looks like the cover of a
motorboat well there are some people
some people are more modern
right i wish i had the i wish i had the
um
i wish i would have the dignity to be
that modest
modest yeah why do you say
because they believe in covering
themselves
and i'm like you said i got to be i
don't have much money i got to be in
this cheap ass plane with all these
people and talking to these people
there's one thing to honest is one thing
completely covering a woman so you don't
see any of her well this isn't modest
that isn't pathological suppose she's
you see look he's now defining what is
pathology pathology is really a
psychological disorder
and what is
i mean you haven't described to us if
you're saying it's pathological what
exactly what pathology is it
how do we classify this pathology it's
not
it's not just about using terms here and
there
they have to have substance
so what are you diagnosing women who
cover in a certain manner with some kind
of psychological disorder which which
disorder is it we would like to know
the point is is that who gets to set the
criterion of who should wear what should
it be you bill because you have a big
platform because you're a white american
should it be your friends and
compatriots
and colleagues
we believe as muslims that the one who
gets to set the guidelines is god
almighty
the one who gets to tell us what is
virtue is god the one who gets to tell
us what is modesty is god the one who
gets to tell us what is
honesty is god and so on and so forth
it's not you who gets to set those
criterion
you have no way of substantiating your
morality in the first instance happy
with that she's not oh my god she's not
happy with it i mean you can brainwash
someone how do you know what she's happy
with and what she's not happy with and
what is happiness
how do you know
what is if she's happy with it or not
this is no longer an academic discussion
they say what have you surveyed them
have you spoke to them
and i got a question for you do you
think that women who wear typical
western dress code
do you think they're happy is there any
evidence that wearing that makes them
more happy than wearing what these other
women are wearing
this is a question as i honestly
do do you not think potentially there's
an argument to be made at least
that for women who get to who are not
privatizing their ornaments
yeah women are not privatizing their
ornaments at least have an
a sense of insecurity which may cause be
a cause of depression and anxiety
could not an argument be made that based
on uh sociological and psychological
investigations which links social media
for example
to
depression and anxiety that that
is because of an exacerbation of
competition uh metrics which include but
are not limited to
one's females ornaments where a woman
now has to compare herself with
not just a thousand other women in her
village but a billion other women in the
world
do not think that that could potentially
be a cause for her depression and
anxiety
are these not arguments that could be
made
so if you're talking about happiness now
what do you think causes happiness do
you think it's feminism
so if that is the case and why is it the
k why is it the case that the longest uh
the longitudinal study that was done
from 1970s to 2000 blanche blanchflower
and oswald indicates
an increased
anxiety and depression of women in the
western world
after so-called reforms were made
legislatively in your country
so unfortunately what you're saying has
no backing and has no substance i think
this bill mah has a bit he's
disrespectful even if you don't accept
this man's religion or what he's his
faith you've got to understand
you're speaking to someone who's
contributed majorly to your country's
culture and you're speaking to him with
all this uh with all this disrespect
have respect you might not agree with
someone's religious beliefs
yeah you might not agree with their
choice of um spirituality
but don't sit there and start you know
think putting yourself in the driver's
seat thinking you're some kind of an
interrogator who are you
why do you think what is this where is
the sanctimony coming from
where is this sanctimoni coming from my
friend
why do you think you've got it right
why do you think all the other world's
cultures should kneel
in humility to you great white men
why do you think that's the case who put
that entitlement in your head
was it your
followers was it was it the payment
you're getting from whatever news
station you're working from
who exactly put you in this position
who that's my question to you
so look i think you need to be educated
with all due respect
yeah you need to be educated because as
as it stands you don't really have much
of an education
you're culturally deplete
you have a lacking of cultural capital
that's you
so next time you speak to someone even
if you disagree with them unless they're
coming
it's not understandable he's not even
coming at you with hostility he's
sitting there
and you're interrogating anyone's
religious beliefs i would suggest that
you change your way
and if you don't
then to you your way and to be mine
was allah
you